I think that these books and Game of
Thrones - are books about power you
agree definitely power the uses of power
the way power does corrupt us also the
way lack of power corrupts us you know
we all know the saying power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
and there's a great deal of truth in
that but also I find the desire for
power can corrupt us the the lust for
power if you will makes people do things
that maybe maybe they shouldn't do even
the people they don't really know what
they want from their leader do you agree
with me because in a way they want a
strong leader but they also want wants
generous leader so it seems to me that
the people don't know what he wants from
a leader I think that's largely true
today - well yes people people have
always wanted strength in in the leaders
although how you define strength is
another issue but certainly in the
medieval times they wanted leaders who
were warriors who you know would be
victorious in war bring plunder and
glory home and maybe that was not really
the wisest of desires you know a king
who never went to war who was led to
drain the realm - decades of peace and
prosperity good harvests economic growth
that would probably be better for most
people but there was this desire to you
know smash the enemy to emerge
victorious we we have all these medieval
battles and poems and and stories about
the great warrior kings who
distinguished themselves in combat we
don't have many stories or songs about
the peaceful king who promoted good
economic
growth and issued some good laws for the
protection of the people so people back
then maybe were no more wiser than
people are today well that's what I was
we are not so much different I think
people been you know hopefully we've
learned a few things with the passage of
the centuries and the societies that
exist in in the world today are by and
large morally and ethically better than
what we had a thousand years ago but
it's not day and night people are people
and we still have the same the same
strengths the same weaknesses and
sometimes the same fears as our ancient
ancestors in these in this new book
there is there is a point that the
people try to kill the dragons because
they want to be free of those of those
kings but then they can't find a leader
and so well this is a spoiler
this one gets them anywhere know where
the people are we the people have to
learn a lot more about about what is
around us just to be free and creates
some kind of democracy that it's better
that the one that we have today well I
think Westeros is still a long way from
democratic-republican there's a there's
a lot a lot of history that remains to
be written but certainly I try to
explore the plusses and minuses the
advantages and disadvantages of the kind
of political unrest and even revolution
if you can say that goes on at certain
points in them in the novels and in the
histories
I mean if you look at a real world you
know we're we're considerably more
advanced than than Westeros is in the
books and we can look on back on the
American Revolution the French
Revolution the Russian Revolution things
that overthrew the ancient regimes of
the past and there's progress there but
there's also you know the French
Revolution gave us some amazing
documents and liberty equality
fraternity but it also gave us the
terror and it also gave us Napoleon and
his attempted conquest of you know all
of Europe so there are there are dangers
there are dangers as well as advantages
and I try to show these things in all
their complexity you can't and shouldn't
simplify these things to monsters it's
never a case of just heroes good guys
and bad guys good guys our bad girls the
good girls are bad girls girls can be
bad too I think I don't know if you
agree with me that we are leaving very
interesting times with these does not
inspire you it depresses me more than
anything else we're living in times that
I wish were rather less interesting but
no I'm if I wanted to write about what
was going on in real world politics in
2019 I'd write something that was closer
to 2019 you know it's the politics of
the Middle Ages that I'm engaged with
now not not the politics of today you
have never had the hunger in you that
wants you to tell to something have you
never read the book you like that
something has already happened like this
don't you know what you're heading into
I feel at all times sometimes I post
about that on my blogs I am a firm
believer and you know those who do not
know history are doomed to repeat it
and you never repeated
exactly though okay you know it's it's
never an exact retread of what it is
before so but I do see when I look
around today's world some some ominous
shadows some ominous reflections of
events of the fairly recent past and of
centuries past and that does alarm
makers they're not they're not good
reflections they're not good times I'm
seeing they're very dark and troubled
times full of conflict and I hope we can
all get past that I hope - thank you
very much no my pleasure